[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم عقب اعلاني واشنطن تزويد
اكياس بمنظومات بيتريات خلال زياره زينسكي
للولايات المتحده وكلمته امام الكونغرس
موسكو تقول ان هذه المنظومات ستكون هدفا
مشروع لها وتعتبر ان توسيع امدادات السلاح
الغربي لاوكرانيا يعرقل التوصل لتسويه
سياسيه سريعه
بعد اقتحام قوات الاحتلال مدينه نابلس
الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني يعلن استشهاد
لاعب كره القدم احمد دراما واصابه 22 شخصا
اخرين بجروح مختلفه كما دعا رئيس الوزراء
الفلسطينيه الفيفا الى ادانه اغتيال
الرياضي الدراغمه ومعاقبه الجنب
غضب وتمديد باستمرار استهداف حكومه الهند
بقياده حزب هات يا جناته الهندوسي
للمسلمين وذلك بعد قيام السلطات الولايات
السامسونج
بالتزاموني مع اضرابات كبرى شامله سكك
الحديديه وقطع التمريض والاسعاف بريطانيا
تشهد المزيد من الاضرابات في قطاع النقل
باعلان عمال الطرق السريعه اضرابا يستمر
اربعه ايام احتجاجا على تدني الاجور